My genetic test had 230 pages, what new developments make the test now 350 pages.
Well, as new genes are researched, they have added new genes to the mix.
So understand, your 230 pages, if I printed the list of your full genetic summary,
and they would only be a gene or a line instead of all those words that you have in a box of it that make 230 pages,
they'd be way over that because they're about a genes that actually are tested are bigger.
So if I, let me do this real quick, so I'll give you an example.
So the summary that I gave you was at that time, that's what was summarized.
I will see how many pages your SNP report would be now.
Okay, finally, it's loading your genetic report there young lady, and you said it was 230 pages before.
Now it's 334 pages.
So it still took the genes that you did it's the test that we're doing doesn't test for any more genes,
but as data and more genes comes available, well, then they're put into different categories.
So, I mean, there's still research coming out on these genes on a weekly basis.
So as that research is categorized, then you, this is categorized as well.
So I could send you this if you want to hear about it.
So it's like, that will be a little bit longer.